est ce que vous connaissez la légende
des escaliers ben on savait que les
correcteurs des concours où des
centaines de dissertation à corriger qui
n'ont pas beaucoup de temps et que ce
n'est pas une tâche passionnante
et bien d'après la légende un jour un
correcteur à trouver une solution
il a monté 20 marche et il a jeté en
l'air son paquet de copies
après ils avaient juste aller ramasser
une par une et à noter le numéro de la
marche là l'élève être déçu
[Musique]
comment s'y prendre pour décrocher vinci
revin en dissertation culture générale
aux concours des grandes écoles de
commerce hec par exemple ou à l'essec
alors c'est tout à fait possible parce
que chaque année des dizaines d'élèves
décroche la note maximale en
dissertation de culture générale en 2010
est par exemple 45 candidats soit 0 6 6
% des candidats ce qui avait fait un peu
plus de 1 sur 2 100 donc en 2010 est un
candidat sur deux sens a eu 20 à la
dissertation de culture générale de la
chaussée seulement ce n'est pas toujours
mérité vous allez voir la copine je vais
commenter dans cette vidéo est loin
d'être parfaite
l'élève a eu un coup de chance et en
effet au concours il y a des surprises
dans les deux sens si vous voulez
réussir la dissertation de culture
générale mais que vous ne voulez pas
vous en remettre à la chance vous avez
besoin d'une méthodologie très efficace
et bien j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie lien doit s'afficher en
haut à droite de la vidéo
vous pouvez aussi le trouver dans la
description c'est un cours par e-mail
donc vous pouvez regarder cette vidéo en
entier
et puis vous découvrirez main
méthodologie après un autre jour alors
maintenant je vous donne les
informations essentielles avant de
commencer à commenter la dissertation
le sujet c'est faut-il toujours préféré
la vérité il est tombé en 2015 à
l'épreuve de l'essec et d'hec qui sont
deux des meilleures écoles de commerce
françaises
le thème de l'année comme vous l'avez
peut être deviné c'était la vérité et
par rapport à ce thème le sujet était
facile déjà c'était une question fermée
et puis beaucoup d'élèves avaient
certainement déjà traité des sujets
comparable dans leur pré page c'est au
cours de l'année à mes yeux c'est même
un sujet niveau bac
en comparaison le sujet qui était tombé
à hec la même année crépuscule de la
vérité était bien plus difficile
concernant la copie vous la verrez à
l'écran pendant mon commentaire vous
verrez le bon passage je soulignerai les
phrases les montre que je mentionne donc
vous n'avez pas besoin de la copie
pendant que vous regardez la vidéo
mais si vous voulez les télécharger je
vous
lien dans la description vous y
trouverez également le minutage de la
vidéo qui vous permettra de la regarder
partie par partie
enfin je vous encourage aussi avec les
vos questions vos remarques vos
suggestions vos compliments vos
critiques ou vos insultes dans les
commentaires allez c'est parti
prenez de quoi noter mettez votre
téléphone en mode avion et
concentrez-vous je rentre dans la
dissertation
[Musique]
alors comme le ferait un correcteur je
commence par me faire une impression
générale de la copie je la regarde
rapidement du début à la fin je trouve
que l'écriture n'est pas super propre
mais ça passe c'est lisible
là je dois déjà m'arrêter parce qu'il y
a une chose qui me choque
vous voyez de quoi je veux parler
l'introduction consiste en un seul et
unique paragraphe ça ça me donne déjà
mal à la tête
il faudrait quelqu'un pour me masser les
tempes pendant que je lis ça me donne
déjà mal à la tête parce que je sais que
ça va être à moins de faire l'effort de
distinguer les enjeux de l'introduction
alors qu'il aurait suffi à l'élève de
les distinguer visuellement c'est
marrant parce que la semaine dernière un
prof particulier m'a contacté à ce
propos il m'a dit que selon un prof de
prépa l'introduction devait tenir en un
seul paragraphe et il a donc suggéré que
j'avais tort de dire aux élèves de faire
plusieurs paragraphes puisque c'est un
prof de prépa qu'il a dit je lui ai
répondu que même si c'était le président
de la république qui l'avait dit san
invaliderait par la consigne parce que
sa pertinence et validé par l'expérience
et par la science interrogés des
lecteurs ils vous diront tous qui
préfèrent lire un texte
subdivisé en paragraphes et en effet les
études scientifiques sur la lecture ont
montré qu'un nouveau paragraphe offre un
genre de respiration à l'oeil
en conclusion si vous voulez rendre la
lecture de votre copie moins pénible oui
parce que ce n'est pas un plaisir pour
le correcteur donc si vous voulez rendre
la lecture de votre copie moins pénible
subdiviser votre introduction en
paragraphes
si vous avez vraiment besoin d'être
rassuré sachez que dans mon stock
personnel et j'ai beaucoup de copies de
concours noté 18 19 20 dans lesquelles
l'introduction est subdivisé en
paragraphes donc ma consigne est bonne
subdivisé l'introduction de votre
dissertation en paragraphes et concentré
chaque paragraphe exclusivement sur un
enjeu précis de l'introduction et si
vous voulez savoir comment rédiger une
bonne introduction aller voir ma vidéo
sur le sujet je continue à descendre
moi ça me dérange vraiment qu'il n'y ait
pas de structure dans l'introduction
alors je remarque déjà de gros défauts
mais j'en parlerai lorsque j'analyserai
le développement dans le détail ce qui
est bien c'est que les paragraphes sont
bien distincts pas comme dans
l'introduction et que les références
sont bien visibles
trois paragraphes dans le grand emprunt
c'est ce qu'il faut une conclusion
partielle pour passer du grand art aux
grands 2 c'est bien le grand 2 ressemble
aux grands un donc c'est bien
ah là je ne vois pas pourquoi il a sauté
une ligne c'est pas grave mais c'est
inutile encore trois paragraphes c'est
bien et puis ils sont de taille
comparable
la conclusion partielle pour passer du
grand de haut rang 3 ok le grand troyes
ressemble au grand deux donc c'est bien
le tout dernier paragraphe paraît un peu
plus court mais ça n'est pas choquant
j'arrive à la conclusion
elle est de taille raisonnable quatre
longues phrases mais tient il a fait
deux paragraphes
lol il est rédigé l'introduction la
partie la plus importante de la
dissertation il la rédige en un seul
paragraphe
et puis il subdivise la conclusion la
partie la moins importante et la plus
petite il la supplie vide en deux
paragraphes
ça montre bien que les élèves suivent
souvent des consignes qu'ils ne
comprennent pas simplement pour obéir à
un prof alors qu'il suffit de réfléchir
à la logique de la consigne je vous le
répète on ne crée pas des paragraphes
pour obéir aveuglément à un prof
mais pour faciliter la lecture de votre
lecteur c'est à dire de votre correcteur
si vous lui faciliter la tâche vous
gagnez des points où vous évitez d'en
perdre alors mon impression générale de
la copie globalement positif la copie
est assez propre
elle est lisible et j'ai trouvé la
plupart des indications qu'on doit
trouver dans une bonne copie le
développement à une structure classique
en trois fois trois paragraphes
ce qui est sérieux après je suis quand
même déçu par le fait que l'introduction
tiennent en un seul gros bloc je sais
déjà que je vais devoir faire un effort
pour la lire attentivement vous dit
peut-être que j'exagère
oui vous avez raison si j'ai une seule
dissertation à corriger mais un
correcteur doit-on lire des dizaines
voire une centaine donc pour réussir une
dissertation de culture générale vous ne
devez jamais oublier la psychologie du
correcteur si vous voulez en savoir plus
j'ai fait une vidéo sur ce sujet bon
maintenant que je me suis fait une
première impression globale de la copie
il est temps de lire le détail de
l'introduction de la dissertation
c'est parti
[Musique]
première phrase de l'introduction dans
le disciple de paul bourget leconte
andré vie des interminables heures
d'angoissé dans sa chambre d'hôtel
faisant face au tribunal c'est parfait
pour commencer la référence un roman
français de la fin du 19e siècle est
noble et pertinente elle parle de la
vérité judiciaire
et puis la phrase est simple et efficace
je continue l'élève développe son
accroche dans les trois phrases
suivantes pourquoi pas mais c'est un peu
long en tout cas c'est parfait sur le
plan de l'expression écrite c'est très
clair fluide et je n'ai trouvé aucune
faute
ses qualités sont cohérentes avec la
note en revanche je n'aime pas la
manière dont ils passent de la croche à
la suite de l'introduction à l'image du
conte andré faut-il toujours préféré la
vérité ce n'est pas catastrophique mais
c'est un parfait sur le plan de la
méthodologie ce n'est pas le moment de
poser le problème dans la dissertation
et c'est aussi un parfait sur le fond en
effet le personnage de la croche leconte
andré ne dit pas toujours la vérité
il l'a juste préféré dans un cas précis
en termes de méthode l'élève aurait pu
faire plus simple
une fois que vous avez développé votre
accroche il suffit de justifier
l'intérêt du sujet il aurait pu écrire
cet exemple nous invite à nous demander
s'il est toujours opportun de dire la
vérité je continue selon et non la
vérité est caractérisée par
l'universalité et l'intemporalité bon
première chose là il fallait évidemment
créer un nouveau paragraphe nouvel enjeu
la définition des termes du sujet donc
nouveau paragraphe
deuxième remarque pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
citent un auteur qui plus aisé non un
philosophe assez peu connue antérieure à
socrate
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils citent un tel
auteur pour définir la notion cardinal
du sujet ce n'était pas nécessaire
troisième remarque c'est quoi cette
pseudo définition c'est bien trop vague
il donne simplement deux
caractéristiques du concept de vérité je
ne vois pas à quoi ça sert ici si vous
voulez définir simplement le concept de
vérité dit que c'est la correspondance
entre un dénoncer et un fait
bien sûr on pourrait développer cette
définition mais ça n'est pas l'enjeu
dans une introduction de dissertation
pour ma quatrième remarque je relis la
phrase selon et non la vérité est
caractérisée par l'universalité et
l'intemporalité
c'est tout ce qu'il nous donne comme
élément de définition parce qu'il
enchaîne directement sur la
problématisation avec la phrase suivante
préférés en toute circonstance la vérité
c'est donc privilégier la quête de la
vérité à tout les autres recherches
comme celle des plaisirs c'est le
premier vrai défaut de la copie l'élève
ne définit pas à sérieusement les termes
de sujets en l'occurrence il suffisait
de définir efficacement le concept de
vérité parce que les autres mots sont
des termes communs qui ne pose aucun
problème de sens j'en profite pour faire
un rappel de méthodologie vous devez
impérativement définir les termes du
sujet dans l'introduction
comme pour la question de la subdivision
de l'introduction au paragraphe des
élèves me disent que leur prof leur
interdit de définir les termes du sujet
dans l'introduction
mais je leur réponds la même chose qu'à
ce qui m'interroge sur la structure dans
l'introduction
même si leurs profs et bac + 50
il a tort parce que c'est la logique
même qui prescrit de définir les termes
du sujet quand vous manipuler un objet
matériel
vous avez besoin de le voir précisément
par exemple vous ne cuisinent et pas
avec un bandeau sur les yeux
en tout cas moi non et bien c'est pareil
pour un objet intellectuelle vous avez
besoin de le voir précisément pour le
manipuler
or voir précisément un concept est bien
c'est le définir avant de manipuler le
concept de vérité avant de le connecter
à d'autres concepts et de le confronter
à des hypothèses et d'en tirer des
conclusions
il faut donc le définir et comme pour la
question des paragraphes dans
l'introduction
j'ajoute que les termes sont définis en
introduction dans plein de bonnes et de
très bonnes copies de concours donc il
n'ya pas à réfléchir
définissez clairement les termes du
sujet dans l'introduction de la
dissertation de culture générale
voilà pour le rappel de méthodologie je
reviens à nos moutons
l'élève a mal définis concept de vérité
puis il est placé à la problématisation
je veux faire une autre remarque sur le
fond maintenant
relisez bien les deux phrases selon les
et non la vérité est caractérisée par
l'universalité et l'intemporalité
préférés en toute circonstance la vérité
c'est donc privilégier la quête de la
vérité à tout les autres recherches
comme celle des plaisirs
vous êtes au courant que donc c'est un
lien logique de conséquences mais emploi
privilégier la quête de la vérité à tout
les autres recherches
c'est une conséquence de la vérité est
caractérisée par l'universalité et
l'intemporalité bas en rire l'élève a
donc créé une fausse connexion logique
il a arnaqué le lecteur enfin le
correcteur par mois il n'ya en réalité
aucun lien logique entre les deux idées
mais il dit explicitement que la seconde
est la conséquence de la première
ça c'est un peu la spécialité des élèves
de sciences po en pratique ça passe
parce que les correcteurs lis très
rapidement les copies mais c'est quand
même risqué si vous le faites à chaque
phrase
le correcteur s'en rendra compte or il
n'est pas maso il n'aime pas qu'on
larnack mieux vaut donc manipuler
honnêtement des idées simples et les
connectés selon leurs véritables liens
en l'occurrence l'élève aurait
simplement dû créer un nouveau
paragraphe revenir à la ligne faire un
alinéa et se passer de lien logique ce
n'est pas grave s'il n'y a pas de
connexion logique entre la croche la
définition des termes je continue
l'élève développe la problématisation
sur trois paragraphes
je les lis rapidement mais c'est aussi
dire la vérité en toute circonstance et
préférer la vérité au mensonge
il semble qu'il faille rechercher et dia
la vérité en toute circonstance car la
vérité est le seul bien aimable et est
nécessaire à la stabilité de la société
mais une telle attitude systématique
peut menacer notre bonheur et nous
conduire à faire le mal bon dans
l'ensemble c'est plutôt efficace il dit
grosso modo on
il peut préférer atteindre la vérité
plutôt qu'autre chose
on peut aussi préférer dire la vérité
plutôt qu'à la terre ou la dissimuler en
effet la vérité est une bonne chose et
la société en a besoin pour fonctionner
mais c'est peut-être dangereux de
toujours préféré la vérité sur le fond
ça se tient
c'est un petit raisonnement pertinentes
sur la forme c'est bon aussi
c'est toujours très claire et fluide
même si je trouve qu'il aurait pu éviter
les répétitions de vérité et en toutes
circonstances après ces trois phrases de
développement de la problématisation il
pose une question alors une telle morale
fondée sur la préférence absolue pour la
vérité peut-elle guider les hommes
j'imagine que c'est la problématique
encore une fois ça aurait été plus
claire en créant un nouveau paragraphe
je n'aurais pas eu à essayer de deviner
l'intention de l'élève alors la question
est plutôt clair mais comme il a déjà
répété l'idée de la préférence de la
vérité dans les phrases précédente
il aurait pu écrire plus simplement une
telle morale peut-elle guider les hommes
comparant la problématique avec l'énoncé
la question du sujet c'est faut-il
toujours préféré la vérité et la
problématique c'est la morale fondée sur
la préférence absolue pour la vérité
peut-elle guider les hommes
les deux questions expriment le même
problème intellectuel et c'est bien
normal parce que ce problème est
transparent dans l'énoncé du point de
vue méthodologique lorsque le sujet est
une question il suffit la plupart du
temps de reformuler l'énoncé pour
rédiger la problématique
je continue après la question de la
problématique
il annonce le plan encore une fois ça
aurait été plus claire en créant un
nouveau paragraphe
lisons son plan dans un premier temps
nous montrerons qu'il est nécessaire de
toujours préféré la vérité mais nous
verrons dans un second temps qu'une
telle moral est inapplicable
enfin à quelles conditions faut-il
privilégier la vérité donc son plan ses
premières idées il faut toujours préféré
la vérité deuxième idée mais en fait ce
n'est pas possible
troisième idée du coup quand est-ce
qu'il faut préférer la vérité je ne vais
pas critiquer le plan à partir du
concept de vérité parce que ça ne va pas
vous servir à grand chose pour vos
dissertation je vais critiquer le plan
du point de vue de la méthodologie le
premier défaut c'est que l'idée du grand
teint et celle du grand deux sont
incompatibles grand teint il faut
toujours préféré la vérité grand deux
ânes on en fait ce n'est pas possible
or le deuxième élément de réponse n'est
pas sensé invalidé totalement le 1er mai
le dépasser en l'incluant c'est à dire
que la première idée doit rester vrai
dans une certaine mesure et la deuxième
idée approfondit les questions avec une
hypothèse plus probable pour corriger le
défaut du plan de l'élève
il faut introduire de la nuance pour le
grand teint il aurait par exemple pu
écrire la préférence pour la vérité
semble tout d'abord ne pas devoir
admettre d'exception
grâce au verbe semblait je montre bien
qu'on est au niveau de l'apparence pour
le grand 2 il aurait pu écrire une
morale fondée sur cette préférence
absolue rencontrerait toutefois des
limites dans la pratique
sur le fond je suis moins radical que
lui je ne dis pas que la morale en
question est inapplicable
j'aimais simplement l'hypothèse qu'on ne
pourra pas l'appliquer parfaitement le
deuxième défaut de son annonce de plan
c'est le grand troyes déjà ce n'est pas
un élément de réponse c'est une question
et puis cette question rappelle grosso
modo le problème de la dissertation
parce qu'on se doute bien qu'on ne peut
pas toujours préféré la vérité et que
donc le problème intellectuel c'est de
savoir quand on doit préférer la vérité
en fait c'est comme s'il n'avait pas
fait de grand froid on verra plus tard
dans le développement s'ils proposent
une vraie idée qui dépasse les 2
premières du plan enfin le troisième
défaut de son annonce de plan c'est
l'expression écrite
il faut au moins une virgule avant le
lien logique d'opposition mais parce
qu'on a besoin de respirer en lisant la
phrase moi je diviserai cette phrase en
deux dans un premier temps nous
montrerons qu'il est nécessaire de
toujours préféré la vérité points nous
verrons dans un second temps d'ailleurs
ici il faut dire deuxième temps et non
pas second parce qu'il y à un troisième
temps nous verrons dans un deuxième
temps qu'une telle moral est cependant
j'ajoute un lien logique pour signaler
l'opposition entre les deux idées une
telle moral est cependant inapplicable
dans l'ensemble l'annnonce de plan est
plutôt efficace mais quand même on
attend mieux d'une copie notée 20 sur 20
si je devais reprendre son annonce de
plan j'écrirai nous montreront tout
d'abord que la préférence pour la vérité
semble ne pas devoir admettre
d'exception nous verrons ensuite une
telle morale reposant sur cette
préférence absolue rencontrerait
toutefois des limites dans la pratique
nous terminerons donc pas rechercher des
critères qui puisse fonder une éthique
de la vérité encore une fois ce n'est
pas mon plan c'est la manière dont je
reformule ray son annonce de plan voilà
c'est bon pour l'introduction
je vais maintenant jeter un oeil à la
conclusion
comme je les dis c'est bien inutile de
subdiviser la conclusion en deux
paragraphes
alors je regarde le premier les deux
phrases rappelle les éléments de réponse
à la problématique
donc c'est ok je passe au second
paragraphe
voilà c'est ce que je craignais ah non
c'est même pire
l'élève commet deux erreurs dans la
première phrase il cite une inférence et
dans la seconde il fait une ouverture ça
ne sert à rien de citer rousseau dans la
conclusion parce qu'on est sortis
l'argumentation et puis terminez la
conclusion par une ouverture je le
déconseille pour les raisons suivantes
vous risquez de souligner une idée qui
aurait mérité de figurer dans le
développement et du coup vous mettez en
évidence une faille dans votre
argumentation
vous risquez d'évoquer une idée banal ou
maladroite
c'est très compliqué à réaliser et bien
sûr on ne vous donne pas de consignes
précises
ça demande une maîtrise de la discipline
et une maturité intellectuelle propre un
prof base à un élève et comme c'est à la
toute fin de l'épreuve
vous manquez probablement de temps là en
l'occurrence il souligne une idée
intéressante qui avait donc sa place
dans le développement
il faut préférer la vérité pour rester
digne
voilà ce que vous devez retenir pour la
conclusion de la dissertation c'est pas
de références ni l'ouverture
contentez-vous de synthétiser les
résultats de la réflexion
ça y est on en a fini avec
l'introduction et la conclusion je sais
c'était long mais encore une fois
l'introduction et la partie la plus
importante de la dissertation
donc c'est normal qu'on y passe du temps
à la cua conclure je trouve qu'il y a
deux défauts principaux et deux qualités
principales
le premier défaut c'est le par ailleurs
unique qui rend la lecture difficile et
déjà beaucoup parler le second défaut
c'est la mauvaise définition des termes
maintenant à la première qualité de
l'introduction de la dissertation c'est
la clarté du propos la lèvre manipule
des idées qu'il maîtrise
il comprend ce qu'il dit et moi aussi et
je comprend d'autant mieux que
l'expression écrite est efficace c'est
ça la seconde qualité
pour l'instant le style est très claire
il n'y a ni maladresse ni faute
manifestement c'est un élève qui écrit
bien et ça c'est un vrai atout en
dissertation parce que la clarté du
style est survalorisé à fond égale 1-1
4-5 se transforme en 7 8 à 8 ans 11-12
1,15 en 18 19 voir enfin vous verrez que
cette copie en est un bon exemple
donc pour résumer deux défauts le
paragraphe unique et l'absence de
définition satisfaisante et de qualité
l'efficacité du propos est celle du
style quant à la conclusion
l'élève se prend la tête pour rien il
essaie d'impressionner le correcteur
mais ça ne change pas grand chose à ce
stade de la correction l'introduction
m'ont fait plutôt bonne impression mais
c'est quand même loin d'être parfait si
j'étais le correcteur je me dirais que
je veux noter la copie entre 13 et 17 le
déciderai de la note finale en lisant le
développement bon allez du coup on y va
[Musique]
je ne vais pas lire le développement
dans le détail mais en diagonale comme
le ferait un correcteur je vais me
concentrer sur les arguments les
références et les transitions let's go
bon ça commence très très mal c'est
quand même fou qu'un correcteur mais de
20 sur 20 à une copie dans laquelle
l'élève site une référence dès la
première phrase du développement le
deuxième mot c'est le nom d'un auteur
si j'étais le correcteur je me dirais
déjà que je ne pourrai pas lui mettre
plus de 12 13 pourquoi parce qu'en
commençant son développement par pour
saint-augustin bla bla bla il révèle
qu'il ne sait pas ce qu'est une
dissertation
ah tiens qu'est-ce qu'une dissertation
c'est un exercice d'argumentation le but
c'est d'apporter des éléments de réponse
intelligente à un problème intellectuel
vous devez convaincre le lecteur de la
pertinence de votre propos en présentant
des arguments c'est à dire des idées
précises les références servent
uniquement à l'intérieur des paragraphes
en soutien des arguments pour leur
apporter du crédit grâce à l'autorité
intellectuelle de l'auteur
si vous citez un ouvrage bref là c'est
catastrophique
moi j'aurais biffé cette phrase en plus
il mentionne deux nouveaux centres
augustin une phrase plus tard
si je devais corriger ce départ raté
j'écrirai en premier lieu les hommes
tendent à investir la vérité d'une
valeur suprême
j'expliquerai ensuite cette idée en
quelques phrases et c'est seulement
après que je ferais référence à
saint-augustin pour étayer mon argument
autre défaut de ce premier paragraphe
l'élève site une deuxième référence ce
n'est pas rédhibitoire mais c'est une
mauvaise décision
en effet je vous recommande d'utiliser
une seule et unique référence par
paragraphe
pourquoi parce que je suis pragmatique
en vous concentrant sur une seule et
unique référence vous avez plus de
chance de choisir la meilleure par
rapport à l'argument vous avez aussi
plus de chances de la mobiliser
intelligemment et enfin vous ne risquez
pas de données aux correcteurs
l'impression vous faites du name
dropping là en citant la seconde
référence
l'élève commet une erreur logique avec
le lien d'illustration ainsi il dit que
la vérité n'est pas soumise au temps
puis il prétend illustrer cette idée en
évoquant un personnage qui hésitent à
abandonner la quête de la vérité
vous voyez le problème idée la vérité
n'est pas soumise au temps exemple ce
mec hésitent à abandonner la recherche
de la vérité
en réalité les deux idées sont
déconnectés mais l'élève voulait citer
voltaire
donc il a encore art laquelle correct
qui manifestement n'est pas à ça près
bref ce que vous devez retenir c'est que
vous améliorez vos chances de décrocher
une bonne note en vous concentrant sur
une seule et unique référence dans
chaque paragraphe du développement après
ce rappel de méthodologie jeu face au
deuxième paragraphe là l'élève commence
bien par un argument de plus il faut
toujours préféré la vérité au mensonge
la phrase est très efficace elle est
courte très claire et elle contient les
mots importants de l'énoncé le nom
commun vérité et l'adverbe toujours je
lui reproche une seule chose elle manque
de nuance j'écrirai plus tôt on devrait
encore préférer la vérité ou mensonge en
dissertation il vaut mieux s'exprimer
avec modération à la fois pour éviter de
rendre les idées incompatibles ce
qu'elle élève a fait dans son plan est
aussi pour éveiller la tolérance du
correcteur je reviens au deuxième
paragraphe l'élève développe son
argument dans la deuxième phrase puis il
introduit une référence ce n'est pas
aussi tôt que dans le premier paragraphe
mais c'est encore trop tôt il aurait pu
développer davantage l'idée de son
argument et puis l'introduction de la
référence pour john stuart mill dans
l'utilitarisme et maladroite
il fallait plutôt d'écrire john stuart
mill explique dans l'utilitarisme que la
confiance etc ou bien citer la référence
entre parenthèses après le nom de
l'auteur c'est un détail mais les très
bonnes copies ne font pas ce genre
d'erreurs dans la suite du paragraphe
les rêves a introduit une autre
référence
je vous ai déjà expliqué pourquoi c'est
une mauvaise des six d'ici en plus
l'exemple n'est pas très pertinent
puisque il montre que le mensonge
dégrade la confiance nécessaire à
l'intimité
alors que l'argument aux 2000 c'est que
le mensonge dégrade la confiance
nécessaire à la coopération
ce n'est pas la même chose comme je vous
l'aï expliqué en commentant le premier
paragraphe
plus vous mobiliser de référence plus
vous risquez de manipuler maladroitement
les idées je passe au 3e paragraphe
alors je trouve l'argument plutôt
efficace enfin la vérité doit toujours
être préférée car elle est bénéfique
pour autrui ce qui est bien c'est qu'on
comprend immédiatement l'idée
on sait aussi qu'elle est pertinent
parce que l'élève reprend l'expression
de l'énoncé toujours préféré la vérité
ça c'est une bonne habitude que vous
pouvez prendre pour persuader le
correcteur de la pertinence de votre
argumentation
vous reprenez systématiquement les
termes clés de l'énoncé dans les
arguments et vous les saupoudrer
également dans le paragraphe là s'est
fait un peu grossièrement mais ça reste
efficace
pas besoin de faire dans la subtilité
pour réussir une dissertation
en fait je lui reproche une seule chose
cette phrase c'est de ne pas nuancé
l'idée la vérité doit toujours être
préférée elle est bénéfique pour autrui
ensuite l'élève développe l'argument en
une seule phrase c'est encore une fois à
trop rapide puis il introduit la
référence avec une phrase très efficace
dans la 4e promenade des rêveries du
promeneur solitaire rousseau distingue
la vérité abstraite de la vérité
particulière
et dans ce dernier paragraphe du grand
emprunt il commet encore l'erreur
d'introduire une seconde référence
il évoque le discours de la méthode de
descartes en une seule phrase ce qui est
vraiment du name dropping tiens j'en
profite pour faire une petite pub pour
mon site
si vous voulez savoir ce qu'il ya dans
le discours de la méthode de descartes
qui est un bouquin vraiment fondamental
dans l'histoire de la pensée et bien
j'ai écrit un résumé détaillé très clair
sur mon blog vous allez sur mille de
culture générale vous écrivez discours
de la méthode dans la barre de recherche
et vous le trouverez je reviens au
dernier paragraphe du grand tant sur le
plan de la rédaction il n'est pas top
il ya trop de répétitions vérité car
donc et puis il ya aussi deux fautes
un ace incompréhensible a en effet et
bannir qui s'écrit ba2 n y r je descends
un peu et j'arrive à la transition entre
le grand 1 et le grand 2 ce que
j'appelle une conclusion partielle
comment le candidat si pontil la
première phrase rappelle l'idée générale
du grand teint la deuxième rappel
l'objection qui amène l'idée générale du
grand 2 et l'élève termine par une
question qui tease un peu le grand 2
c'est carré est clair c'est très
efficace
après moi je vous conseille de vous
passer de la question parce que c'est
plus difficile à rédiger les deux
premières phrases suffisent
alors qu'est ce que je peux dire sur eux
quand un an synthèse j'ai quand même été
déçus que l'élève commence un paragraphe
par une référence ça me choque qui l'on
mobilise deux par paragraphe ça me
dérange
et puis forcément ils ne développent pas
assez les références après il faut
reconnaître que ce grand a des qualités
les arguments sont pertinents le propos
est structuré le style est efficace et
j'ajoute que les références à la fois
philosophique et littéraire a les
références sont bonnes mais bon de là à
mettre 20 sur 20 je me dis que le paquet
copie devait vraiment être mauvais en
plus le sujet n'était pas difficile
bon allez on se plonge dans le grand 2
[Musique]
si c'était la copie d'un élève de ma
formation je m'énerverais non mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut commencer un
paragraphe de dissertation en écrivant
tout d'abord pour nietzsche il est
dangereux de toujours préféré la vérité
je vous en ai déjà parlé mais je le
répète ne fait surtout pas ça un
paragraphe de dissertation commence par
un argument en l'occurrence ils
suffisent à décrire préféré
systématiquement la vérité peut s'avérer
dangereux mon argument est court très
clair je reprend les termes clés de
l'énoncé j'ai remplacé l'adverbe
toujours pas systématiquement et je
présente l'idée comme une hypothèse je
reviens ce texte de l'élève
regardez sa deuxième phrase dans volonté
de puissance nietzsche décrit le monde
comme un chaos de force mouvante qui
n'admet aucune fixité quel est le lien
avec la précédente
il y en a aucun le candidat recrache
simplement son cours après ce qui est
bien c'est qu'il développe la référence
sur plusieurs phrases 4 précisément mais
il refait l'erreur de mobiliser une
seconde référence s'il avait commencé
son paragraphe pas un argument et s'il
avait expliqué un peu l'idée de cet
argument il n'aurait pas eu besoin d'une
référence supplémentaire
et puis l'introduction de cette seconde
référence est trop abrupte il faut
accompagner le lecteur l'élève aurait dû
lui expliquer plus clairement pourquoi
on se met à parler d'un roman de balzac
maintenant il aurait par exemple pu
l'écrire tout simplement balzac donne
vie à cette idée dans le père goriot
sinon encore une fois la référence est
balayée en deux phrases c'est trop
rapide sur le plan de la rédaction on
retrouve les mêmes défauts que dans le
grand teint trop de répétitions
nietzsche apparaît quatre fois en six
phrases et vérité apparaît six fois
ça manque aussi de nuances allez je
passe au paragraphe sur la on a à faire
un véritable argument de plus dire la
vérité en toute circonstance peut
également faire du mal c'est une idée
pertinente
il n'y a pas de référence et le verbe
pouvoir apporte de la modération
ce qui n'est pas super c'est la
répétition du lien logique d'addition de
plus est également moi j'aurais écrit
uniquement également dire la vérité en
toute circonstance peut également faire
du mal et par ailleurs l'expression
faire du mal n'est pas terrible est trop
vague
j'aurais dit plus précisément que la
vérité peut blesser autrui
je continue le candidat développe l'idée
de l'argument sur deux phrases c'est
bien il introduit ensuite un exemple
littéraire qu'il développe jusqu'à la
fin donc c'est très bien
le style est toujours aussi efficace
c'est le meilleur paragraphe depuis le
début si tous les autres avaient suivi
ce modèle j'aurais pu comprendre que le
correcteur met 20 sur 20 petit détail
ça ce sont des guillemets anglais or
vous devez utiliser des guillemets
français parce que vous écrirez en
français allez je regarde le dernier
paragraphe je l' ai déjà dit au tout
début je ne vois pas pourquoi il a sauté
une ligne il faut rester cohérent c'est
à dire appliquer les mêmes choix tout au
long de la copie ce paragraphe comment
suis aussi par un véritable argument
enfin il ne faut pas toujours préféré la
vérité car elle peut menacer la
stabilité sociale c'est clair et nuancée
donc c'est bien
après on pourrait faire plus court par
exemple préférez toujours la vérité peut
menacer la stabilité sociale je trouve
aussi que le candidat ne varie pas assez
son vocabulaire
comme pour le grand teint il commence le
dernier paragraphe par enfin c'est
certes efficace mais ça fait un peu
mécanique et puis comme dans le deuxième
paragraphe de ce grand teint il modère
l'idée avec le verbe pouvoir à la place
il aurait pu utiliser le conditionnel
préférez toujours la vérité menacerait
la stabilité sociale mais bon dans
l'ensemble l'argument reste efficace et
puis maintenant qu'on lit de vrais
arguments on ne va pas se plaindre je
continue à analyser ce paragraphe
le candidat développe l'argument sur
deux phrases il remarque intelligemment
qu'il a affirmé le contraire dans le
grand teint pourtant nous avons établi
en première partie c'est pour éviter ce
problème qu'il faut modérer les
arguments sinon on se contredit on
présente des hypothèses dans une grande
partie comme ça on peut dire dans une
autre grande partie qu'il existe aussi
des raisons qui rendent les hypothèses
contraire crédible là en l'occurrence il
suffisait de dire que la vérité
contribuer à la stabilité sociale dans
certains cas et kelly nuit dans d'autres
donc jouer la sécurité
préférez la nuance je reviens au texte
l'introduction de la référence pour
pascal dans ces trois discours sur la
condition des grands et maladroite il
faut écrire
pascal affirme dans ses trois discours
sur la condition des grands que
blablabla
ou bien pascal considère que la cohésion
sociale blabla et mettre le titre entre
parenthèses à la fin en revanche le
candidat développe la référence jusqu'à
la fin c'est une bonne chose
je rappelle qu'il faut d'utiliser des
guillemets français je descends et
j'arrive à la conclusion partielle du
grand 2 la première phrase rappelle
l'idée de la grande partie puis deux
questions tease
la grande partie suivante ce n'est pas
la méthode que je recommande mais c'est
suffisant inutile de se prendre
davantage la tête alors que conclure du
vent de cette grande partie a très mal
commencé mais j'ai enfin l'ue devrait
paragraphe avec un argument développé
puis soutenu nos un second temps par une
référence elle même développés en termes
d'organisation des idées je pense que
j'aurai terminé par celle qu'il a
présentée en premier parce que c'était
la moins évidente
j'aurai donc commencé en disant que la
vérité peut blesser autrui
j'aurais enchaîné en disant qu'elle peut
nuire à la stabilité sociale et j'aurai
terminé en expliquant qu'on peut aussi
concevoir la vérité comme l'expression
d'une morale inférieur comme ça mon
raisonnement progresse de l'idée la plus
évidente à la moins évidente
c'est lors de présentation des idées le
plus efficace en dissertation
sinon le style est toujours aussi
efficace les liens logiques sont
toujours les mêmes tout d'abord de plus
enfin en effet car donc on est quasiment
que ça mais c'est suffisant pour réussir
une dissertation comme dans le grand
teint les références sont bonnes elles
sont à la fois philosophique et
littéraire
je remarque tout de même qu'il n'ya
aucune référence originale pour
l'instant il n'y a aucune pépite comme
disent certains correcteurs et ce n'est
pas très cohérent avec la note
mais bon je lui ai dit depuis le début
cette copie a été sûr noté en conclusion
seconde est meilleur que le grand teint
hâlé on passe au grand troyes
[Musique]
alors première phrase du grand troyes
tout d'abord le sujet doit faire preuve
de prudence afin de bien décidés
lorsqu'il doit préférer la vérité bon
déjà c'est un véritable argument le
candidat a pris le pli il était
peut-être stressé au début de la
dissertation il pensait aux correcteurs
et il se disait il faut que je lui donne
sa dose la grande partie commence encore
par tout d'abord mais bon la structure
est simple et explicite donc c'est
efficace
en revanche l'argument qui porte sur la
prudence monk lui-même de prudence mieux
vaut écrire par exemple la prudence
semble nécessaire pour décider si la
vérité est opportune l'élève lui a
répété le verbe devoir ensuite il a
introduit directement une référence
c'est bien sûr trop tôt et en plus ils
ne consacrent que deux phrases à la
référence comme dans le grand bain et de
legrand 2 il introduit une seconde
référence
encore une fois je préciserai pour le
confort du lecteur que la référence
illustre l'idée que je viens d'évoquer
j'écrirai par exemple marguerite
yourcenar illustre le rôle de la
prudence à l'égard de la vérité dans les
mémoires d'hadrien
sinon le développement de la référence
est intéressant moi je me serais passé
de sites et aristote j'aurais d'abord
expliqué avec mes propres mots en quoi
il peut être nécessaire d'anticiper les
effets de la révélation de la vérité
puis je réside lustré cette idée en
développant davantage la référence aux
mémoires d'hadrien la dernière phrase du
paragraphe est efficace pour rappeler
l'argument mais encore une fois je
modère
idée et cela d'autant plus que
l'argument suivant soutient une
hypothèse différentes
j'écrirai plus tôt l'homme aurait donc
intérêt à être pragmatique dans son
rapport à la vérité en effet l'idée du
premier argument c'est de dire qu'il
faut préférer la vérité en analysant ses
potentiels effets celle du deuxième
argument c'est qu'il faut la préférée en
analysant l'intention je clarifie
premier argument si les effets
potentiels sont dont il faut dire la
vérité
deuxième argument si l'intention est
bonne il faut la dir ce sont des idées
bien différente donc encore une fois il
faut présenter les arguments avec
modération pour éviter de donner
l'impression qu'on se contredit je
reviens aux textes comme dans le premier
paragraphe
l'élève commence par un vrai argument de
plus le sujet doit privilégier la vérité
lorsque son intention visent le bien
puis il enchaîne immédiatement avec une
référence qui l'introduit et
maladroitement pour caen dans la
critique de la raison pratique il
fallait plutôt d'écrire quand avance
dans la critique de la raison pratique
que blablabla
l'argument est plutôt efficace mais on
retrouve encore les mêmes défauts
toujours le même lien logique pas de
modération il ne consacre que deux
phrases à la référence puis il en
introduit une seconde en revanche cette
fois ci il le fait intelligemment et il
pense à son lecteur il reprend un
exemple passer sous un nouvel angle
et il dit explicitement que l'exemple
sert à illustrer l'idée qu'il vient
d'évoquer l'exemple da de moulins
courdent fergus doit donc être
réévaluées à la lumière de ce nouveau
critère c'est beaucoup plus facile à
lire
c'est fluide il développe un peu
l'exemple
puis il rappelle l'idée du paragraphe on
peut remarquer qu'il la présente avec
nuance semble être un bon guide
cette formulation apporte un peu d'air
frais parce que le candidat utilise
beaucoup les verbes
voir et pouvoir depuis le début de la
dissertation sur le plan du style c'est
globalement efficace mais je note qu'il
ya encore trop de répétitions par
exemple sujet circonstances allez on
passe au tout dernier paragraphe de la
dissertation
je lis l'argument enfin la vérité doit
être préférée si et seulement si le
sujet a mené un travail philosophique
suffisant pour en mesurer la pureté
c'est un véritable argument en revanche
c'est un peu hors sujet sur le fond
parce que l'élève dit il faut préférer
la vérité si c'est vraiment la vérité
or le problème c'est de savoir s'il faut
toujours préféré la vérité en partant du
principe que c'est la vérité vraie comme
on dit mais bon je ne suis pas censé
parler du fond sur la forme la phrase
est plutôt efficace
on comprend facilement l'idée après il
ya toujours les mêmes défauts le dernier
paragraphe comment sont encore par enfin
je ne lui demande pas de faire du crous
tu mets ça serait bien de varier un peu
et du coup 20 sur 20 ce n'est pas mérité
autre défaut récurrent le manque de
modération dont son responsable le verbe
devoirs et l'allocution mathématique si
et seulement si enfin la phrase est un
peu longue pour être un argument
j'aurais par exemple formulé l'idée de
la manière suivante il paraît encore
nécessaire d'estimer la pureté de la
vérité avant de la préférée je regarde
la suite du paragraphe le candidat
introduit encore une fois la référence à
la deuxième phrase c'est à dire bien
trop tôt ce qui est bien c'est qu'il l'a
développe sur la forme il y a encore les
mêmes défauts que dans les paragraphes
précédents
trop de répétitions vérité apparaît huit
fois en cette phrase et foucault trois
fois
ce n'est pas très grave mais ces
imperfections de style devrait retenir
le correcteur de donner 20 sur 20 autre
détail les guillemets anglais après
l'expression écrite et restent efficaces
notamment grâce aux liens logiques
voilà pour le grand troyes pour conclure
mon commentaire je vais reprendre la
méthode que j'applique pour corriger les
copies des élèves de ma formation je
vais vous donner les trois principaux
défauts puis les trois principales
qualités de la dissertation et enfin je
vous dirai quel mode j'aurais donné à
cette copie alors le plus gros défaut de
la copie c'est l'introduction
vous vous souvenez elle est d'un seul
bloc ce qui la rend pénible à lire elle
n'est pas idéal du point de vue de la
méthodologie
après on est d'accord il y a pire mais
bon vin sur vin encore une fois c'est
sur nos terres ensuite le deuxième
principal défaut c'est l'expression de
l'argumentation et je dis bien
expression parce que les arguments les
idées en elles-mêmes elles sont plutôt
pertinente mais vous vous souvenez à de
nombreuses reprises l'élève commence
directement le paragraphe par une
référence or ça c'est rédhibitoire
on ne peut pas donner 20 à un candidat
qui n'a pas parfaitement compris ce
qu'est une dissertation
enfin troisième défaut principal la
gestion des références je vais répéter
dans mon commentaire c'est une mauvaise
idée de mobiliser plusieurs références
dans un même paragraphe
et puis dans cette copie ça confine au
name choper une référence ne doit
apparaître côtières ou à la moitié du
paragraphe
une fois que vous avez présenter et
expliquer votre argument c'est alors que
vous pouvez vous servir d'une autorité
extérieure pour donner plus de crédit à
votre argument de ce point de vue cette
copie n'est pas bonne
voilà pour les trois principaux défauts
maintenant les trois principales
qualités
la première c'est la pertinence du
propos
90% du temps l'élève et dans le sujet et
il perd soit vraiment le lecteur que
c'est le cas en répétant
systématiquement les termes clés du
sujet préférez toujours et bien sûr ils
répètent à l'excès vérité
retenez cette technique parce qu'elle
est vraiment efficace un peu comme quand
on écrit un article pour arriver en
première page de google
il faut répéter les termes clés du sujet
pour persuader le correcteur de la paire
finances du propos deuxième principale
qualité l'efficacité du style oui ce
n'est pas très élégant mais on comprend
toujours et on comprend vite les lèvres
prend systématiquement la même triade
tout d'abord de plus enfin c'est
monotone c'est mécanique
mais ça ne risque pas de perdre le
correcteur il peut lire la copie
facilement et très rapidement
le candidat lui facilite la tâche dont
kg et compense comme je le dis souvent
la clarté du style est survalorisé en
dissertation si vous faciliter la tâche
du correcteur même de manière grossière
comme dans cette copie vous
transformerez 1 8 12 13 en 12 15 16 et 1
15 16
en 18 19 20 enfin troisième qualité
principale la qualité des références
elles sont toutes bonnes elles sont
toutes pertinentes
certaines sont philosophique d'autres
littéraire après il aurait pu mobiliser
quelques références originales
surtout qu'il a cités beaucoup de
références là aussi il décroche la note
maximale alors que son travail n'est pas
exceptionnel sur le plan des références
alors maintenant quelle note mérite
cette copie je viens de vous lever ainsi
efficace permet d'être sûr noté en
particulier 1,16 peut se transformer en
1 19
en l'occurrence je pense que la copie
vaut moins que 16 comme elle présente de
sérieux défauts avec le sujet était
plutôt facile sur le thème de la vérité
il était assez probable que les
candidats y déjà traité un sujet
similaire donc pour ces deux raisons les
défauts et la facilité du sujet moi je
donnerai plus tôt entre 13 et 15 comment
expliquer que la copie était sûr noté à
ce point je pense qu'il ya trois raisons
principales la première c'est que le
correcteur a dû la lyre très rapidement
mais bon le concours c'est comme ça
celle usine la deuxième raison c'est que
l'élève facilite vraiment le travail du
correcteur donc il est récompensé c'est
bien normal
enfin la troisième raison que je vois
c'est que le paquet de copies ne devait
pas être terrible
c'est sûr que si les dissertations
corrigé juste avant celle ci sont
vraiment mauvaises et bien par effet de
contraste
celle ci peut apparaître très bonne et
le correcteur sur un moins sensibles aux
défauts bon après ce n'est pas
scandaleux non plus le candidat a eu un
peu de chance mais c'est quand même un
élève qui a travaillé et qui maîtrisent
globalement
l'exercice de la dissertation
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que vous devez retenir
de ce commentaire je pense qu'il y a
trois leçons à tirer
la première je viens de vous en parler
mais je répète parce que c'est important
la première leçon à retenir c'est que
vous devez faire le maximum pour
faciliter la tâche du correcteur ci lui
qui tient à votre sort entre ses mains
donc vous devez tout faire pour vous le
mettre dans la poche ça passe par
l'efficacité du style mais aussi par la
propreté de la copie par la simplicité
de la construction du propos et c'est la
deuxième leçon c'est que le concours
récompense les élèves scolaire il n'y a
pas besoin d'être un génie pour
cartonner il n'y a pas besoin de
connaître tous les ans auteur de les
avoir lus dans le texte il n'y a pas
besoin d'écrire comme proust
il suffit de maîtriser l'exercice est de
faire ce qu'on attend de vous c'est tout
avec cette copie le candidat n'a pris
aucun risque
il applique des techniques très simple
ils réutilisent même une formulation ou
pour a comme l'impression qui fait du
copier coller il fait de mauvais choix
commet des maladresses mais il fait ce
qu'on attend de lui
je n'accepterai jamais publié une
dissertation comme celle ci sur mais
l'idée de culture générale mais pour une
épreuve de concours ça suffit tiens
pourquoi est-ce que je ne publierai
jamais une dissertation comme celle ci
parce que c'est un mauvais modèle bien
sûr le candidat a eu 20 sur 20 mais avec
un certain correcteurs dans un certains
paquets de copies sur un certain sujet
et c'est ce que je veux dire c'est que
la méthodologie de cette élève n'est pas
réplicable si vous disserter comme lui
vous n'aurez pas 20 sur 20 est en
réalité pas mal de copie très bien
notées sont deux mauvais modèle c'est ce
que j'appelle les faire retourner de
ronaldo
d'accord c'est un geste magnifique mais
ce que vous croyez que c'est ce qu'on
doit apprendre aux enfants dans les
écoles de foot bien sûr que non parce
que ça marche une fois sur son bien
c'est pareil pour cette copie ne vous en
inspirer pas parce que vous aurez 20 sur
20 une fois sur 100 si vous voulez
apprendre une méthodologie de la
dissertation qui marche à tous les coups
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits par
e-mail le lien doit s'afficher
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
mais vous pouvez aussi le trouver dans
la description
voilà voilà j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu et qu'elle vous sera utile si
vous avez des questions n'hésitez pas à
laisser un commentaire et puis souvenez
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour réussir une dissertation
[Musique]